I want to have a bad day and I can't
like I can't even be overwhelmed and
have a bad day because
no one else has their together all of
his Shenanigans is going to be far more
damaging to the kids one day
then my tape will ever be that's right
and I have to sit here
and not say anything ever
because I know one day my kids will
appreciate that yes we all know who
Kim's referring to Kanye who was just
spotted out wearing shoulder pads and
socks for shoes during an outing with
reported new wife Bianca censuri season
three of the Kardashians premiered on
Hulu today and unlike last season the
fam brought it Kim hinted her breakup
with Pete was Mutual there was like a
lot of guilt I he went through a lot
because
you know my relationship
and Chloe his name is Tatum so Tatum and
true that baby name reveal came a little
late since Chloe's bestie seemingly
revealed it in this oopsie post last
week as for Courtney and Travis we are
officially done with IVF we would love a
baby more than anything but I just
really believe in what God has in store
for us if that's a baby then I believe
that it will happen the family just
Inked a mega deal for 20 more episodes
and later this season Kim drops her wish
list for the perfect man protect me
fight for me good hygiene calm no mom or
dad issues patient supportive no heavy
baggage I have enough